I did a pilot with Brooke Shields she
didn't say one word to me yeah but if I
was Brooke Shields I wouldn't say
anything to you either just afraid of
sexual assault from you she's heard what
goes on
she knows what did you do to Brooke
Shields Robert Robert real
yeah it's getting real if I was hot hot
girl Brooke Shields why would I not talk
to you yeah I mean the writing's on the
wall I'm not as interesting I love
talking to you I'm Brooke Shields right
now no thanks
so good and that's why I played it the
way I just did I know you did you did a
good job you see what I did you did a
good job
that's called [ __ ] mind twists who's
that who is the who is the best looking
person in Hollywood that's been nice to
you oh [ __ ] that's a good one Mike the
best-looking one yeah or ma'am doesn't
matter guy I think guys are always more
that guy Joe Oh Mangan Manganiello oh
he's handsome he's gorgeous Joe
Manganiello I've had sushi a couple
times with and you know he's a big guy
big guy yeah and he doesn't when I hug
him yeah he doesn't do big guy [ __ ] like
he doesn't squeeze you make you feel no
like said they'll pick me up on my neck
or you know me or whatever right yeah he
holds me like oh gentle little flower in
fact I know this for a fact that he's
done projects and stuff and he's
mentioned my name I heard that from
other showrunner or some people if they
say you know he says you know you should
get his Bobby yeah yeah he like he's
that kind of guy and well whether or not
I work with him that's one thing but I
really like him he's also very
good-looking who's the ugliest person
that you've been friends with Ken Jong
no hesitation the ugliest man you've
ever was not that he's ugly it's just
that he looks like he has that brittle
bone disease
right when I love him so much by the way
okay
osteogenesis imperfecta but yeah hey
guys you know and he's like he always
stands like this with us and his potty
is like there's no chest plates or
anything you know tragic car accident he
was young you know that that's not true
yes it is look at me yes it is
[Laughter]
god I love Ken I love him too he's a
wonderful guy great you say he's the
most no he's not ugly as I was kidding
who's getting everything I'm trying to
think that just came out of my head who
I think that's ugly let's talk about
who's ugly with a woman that was this
dude this dude you've ever worked with
I'm going to think of it I think the
ugliest do opener is um I mean Hayes's
Trejo is not really you think he's like
that he's his trio is like a barman and
Barnum and Bailey's kind of circus
people [ __ ] are you talking about he's
just got when he opens his eyes there's
all these gums he looks like a normal
dude he died you kid him [ __ ] me the
scratch
Tim Burton I'm gonna show you a photo
let's just see what the first photo like
I'm driving with a with a top down and
his hair just like flapping what is this
he's a tree ho no I'm saying what is it
it's like a sketch or something no he
just put up this video of him on
Instagram Oh making fun of his parents
first photo that comes up right yeah I
think is a very normal so normal he's a
very normal looking dude
well Mexican kid I guess I don't know
show the team show the kid oh no I am
normal-looking guy Mexican guy maybe
you're right maybe you're right
max maybe you're riot okay here's a
better I think it's you don't like
Mexicans I know here's a better here's a
better he's just not into pork tooth to
gum Ryu mm-hmm the gum thing bothers you
yeah yeah but it's not don't want to
when you open your mouth I don't want to
know if you have gingivitis or not
that's all you know like noona smile I
just want to see the teeth part yeah if
you you hold do the bug arms - yeah that
you're right it's too much for me you
know when you see someone's really bad
teeth and they're talking to you and you
can't stop looking at their teeth that
that's hard for me to not look if you a
bad teeth I keep staring at your teeth
yeah and I know they know I know they
know in fact I was watching a porn a
couple of months ago
oh no and um
a girl opened her mouth and she had two
teeth nothing on this side I just turned
it off
I was I was it's so angry it was gross
because she got everything else done
you're right except it's right mm-hmm
she got like you know the tan right
tanta shave shave makeup nice makeup
hair the whole thing and then [ __ ]
you know mean jagged - yeah in men
though with bad teeth not bad teeth when
they're missing teeth right a lot of
times MMA fighters like after the fight
he is missing teeth well but mighty it's
not in the back my teeth missing all
over my not in the front but even the
front all I have is front that's all you
need
they don't see the who sees the back but
I have no back have you seen it go look
go up up a little bit like an 80 year
old woman like a whole this woman right
like you broke your teeth on were too
many Werther's Originals he just cracked
him back and let him go so you're hot
you're hot with guys that do that yeah
like I think I remember watching was it
Dan Henderson an MMA fighter yeah and he
um he took his two front teeth out after
his fight and that turn you on huh I did
what do you like that
I know it was like he just went through
some [ __ ] in life yeah like he didn't
want his teeth to fall off but somehow
like life dealt him like some cards and
his you know he just lived a little and
he's okay with it yeah as long I'm just
weird about breath but I'm not I'm cool
with you missing a few T's breath is
what you got to have bet you gotta have
good I actually like people I'm more
attracted to people who have not perfect
teeth I don't like perfect teeth great
yeah when someone's got like perfect
teeth yeah there's no fairy American
Psycho about that yes yeah I don't like
super bright speed which I have to get
this fixed I have a chip in my front
tooth and I can feel with my [ __ ]
tongue every day it drives me nuts I can
feel it
that's getting worse and I'm gonna lose
this tooth I don't know I can't see a
difference if I lose this Friday I look
at your my don't see a chip that's
[Music]